the pandemic has brought to the fore a
whole host of legal challenges when it
comes to workers rights the most recent
capturing headlines this week the convoy
of truckers and their supporters
protesting covet 19 mandates
specifically one that would require
cross-border truckers to be
double-vaxxed in order to avoid
quarantine but for those not in
compliance with that federal mandate
what legal rights do they have
employment lawyer leo samfero is here to
weigh in on this and other employment
news good morning leora thanks for
joining us good morning
so let's get right to it can an
unvaccinated trucker lose their job if
it affects their ability to transport
across the border because of the mandate
so with this mandate that has been
created the effect of that is that a
trucker now is not able to do their job
they're not able to properly cross the
border deliver their a load and come
back and because of that an employer is
faced with a dilemma i have a worker
that can't do their job so what happens
in that situation given the fact that
it's not the employer's fault it's not
the employer making a decision to
not have the employee work that employer
is able to terminate the trucker without
any compensation for not being able to
do the job we as often refer to this
also as frustration of contract so for
this truckers it is bad news because in
normal situations you will get
compensated right now in this particular
situation you can lose your job no
compensation obviously that's not very
good
you know in other industries there's uh
you know i wouldn't say a requirement
but an expectation that accommodation is
made in some cases are trucking
companies not required to to do that as
well perhaps by way of another route
maybe a domestic route if they can't
cross the border what is considered
reasonable accommodation in this sector
so a trucking company or an employer
generally is not required to change the
job to accommodate an employee's
vaccination status now where a trucker
doesn't often drive across border they
mostly drive within
the border then an employer is expected
to work with them to make it happen so
that they don't have to cross the border
anymore or where it's a real and
fundamental term of employment that you
cross the border you're the guy that
crosses the border the employer in this
case is not required to change that to
make it different to give them a
different route they can simply say
unfortunately you can't do the job and
until that happens or until that changes
you you don't work here so that
accommodation requirement is going to be
quite limited here